what is going on everybody and welcome
to an updated starcraft 2 ai tutorial
series uh if you don't know starcraft 2
is a sort of strategy based game where
you've got units and buildings you build
these buildings you can build units
based on certain buildings that you have
and you need certain buildings to build
certain buildings and anyways you're
trying to compete against other players
either one player or possibly multiple
other players
and the idea is that you build units you
attack and you also collect like
resources stuff like that it's a very
big um and still to this day very
popular strategy
step based game so
i am by no means a starcraft 2 expert if
you are an expert awesome i'm not so you
can talk all the smack that you want but
hopefully what i um employ here can help
you to employ your expert strategy there
are also ai ladders and stuff like that
where you can compete with other experts
just like yourself
if you really need that outlet so for me
i'm mostly interested in this as more as
like a sandbox environment just to play
around uh and then also to
possibly develop reinforcement learning
algorithms like with this environment
but that said at least for the first few
tutorials this is all going to be like a
rule-based strategy ai so anybody can
follow along no matter what you're
interested in
so uh to get started what you are going
to need is um we're going to be using
this package here it's just python-sc2
i'll just put the link to this github in
the description because the actual
initial setup of everything
is going to depend widely and vary
widely depending on your operating
system but for the most part you need
starcraft 2. to get starcraft 2 you can
theoretically get it on windows mac and
linux but as you can probably tell i am
on windows i made made the attempt i
gave it the old college try to get
starcraft 2 to run on linux via like
wine and proton and stuff i just
couldn't get it to work and i just
decided okay i'm gonna dual boot into
windows so that's what i did feel free
to to use linux if you can otherwise
windows
and all that so so make sure you have a
working version there is a headless
version of starcraft 2 that does run on
linux very easily um but you really need
to like see the game i mean you don't
have to you could print stuff out and
you could debug that way but seeing it
is
i don't know it's like 90 percent of
what makes this fun so i think you want
to be able to see it
so with that out of the way once you've
got starcraft 2 for some weird reason
when you install starcraft 2 it comes
with no maps so you have to download
these maps i feel like there should be
like some starting maps but there are
not
so anyways once you download those they
come in these like packs you extract
them and what you'll need to do is come
over to your if you're on windows for
example programming or program files
starcraft 2 and then you'll i had to
make a new directory called maps and
place the maps within that directory
uh for this tutorial at least for the
first few i'm going to be using this
right here uh this this map i will put a
link in the description to where you can
download that map but you don't have to
use this exact same map so for some
reason that map goes missing or whatever
um
there's like a eula that you have to
sign otherwise i would host the map
myself but if it goes missing you can
just use a different map i mean it's not
essential that you use the exact same
map as i'm using
so
with that out of the way
once you have that and also this here
you can find there's like bot ladders
you can go here if you're interested in
doing like the se2 ai ladder competition
type stuff other than that i think we're
ready to just start diving in so
i find it to be pretty well documented
but i think the best thing you can do if
you really want to learn how to like do
all this stuff is just to kind of dive
in
so a couple things to think about
actually let's just start writing the
code and then we'll kind of talk about
we'll come up to this page probably
pretty quickly i guess since i'm here
i'll just point it out so i don't have
to bring it back
so within starcraft 2 there are again
i'm not a starcraft 2 expert this is my
understanding of everything so
take it with the grand salt uh there's
like three races you've got uh protoss
zerg and tehran so taran are like the
humans i suppose zerg are like i don't
know insects and stuff and
protoss are like robots or something
like that um so i like protoss purely
because they look cool so that's what
i'm going with but again you don't have
to do everything the way i'm gonna do it
although i would probably since there
are so many different building names and
like the strategy of what you might do
is going to vary by race uh you might
want to follow along with the same race
for this series but the other thing to
take note of before we dive in is like
here for example if you want to
like immediately as long as you have a
unit to do so you could build a nexus
you could build an assimilator and you
could build this like pylon
but if you want to build for example a
cybernetics core that means you must
have a nexus and a gateway like building
in place before you could build that
cybernetics core and at least for us
we're eventually going to get to
building a stargate and building those
void rays that's what i did last time
and i think that's a pretty good unit i
like the unit it shoots laser beams so
so that's kind of the the trajectory
that we'll take but we'll also use the
canons for some basic bass defense
so
different races are going to have
different building names and different
kind of things that you would build and
probably different units that you would
want to use so just keep that in mind so
there's that and then also
i don't really think there's anything
else we'll talk about the things as we
come across them in the code so
with that let me move this out of the
way
and we begin so uh for our very very
basic starting code uh what i'm gonna do
is from sc2 dot bot underscore a i we're
gonna import bot
a let me check the casing on this yes
okay bot ai
so this is just your parent ai class
that that you'll
inherit from so uh when you actually
make your bot ai object or your your bot
ai class it's going to inherit various
things from this like main kind of
parent class here
so moving on we've got from sc2.data
we're going to import
difficulty and we will
import race so when we go and define our
race and then the computer bots race
we'll use that and then the computer's
difficulty from here as well
next we have from
sc2.main we're going to import run
run game uh this is just something that
facilitates the ability to actually run
two agents against each other uh next we
have from
sc2.player
we're going to import a bot type of
player that will be like what we write
so if you want to run from a script it's
going to be a bot and then you also have
computer
computer
finally from sc2 we're going to import
maps so again this is just a helper for
loading maps
so now we're ready to actually build our
our bot so we'll call it whatever the
heck we want i'm going to call it
incredibot
and again it is going to inherit from
that bot ai that we imported up here
so incredibot um we'll just start really
basically so async
define on step
uh
self
and then what iteration are we at that
should be an integer
and
uh then we'll just gonna print a simple
f string
uh
the iteration is
and
put a space there and we'll do iteration
okay that should be good and then we'll
we'll just run the game so all we're
going to do is just print that statement
and run the game so run
game
and then we'll do maps dot get and again
i'm going to use this 2000
atmosphere
[Music]
s atmospheres a i e
and but you can use any other map like
you don't have to use this exact map
then it'll be a list of the players and
in this case first we're going to have a
bot player that's going to be us
we're going to pass race dot protoss
and the
class basically or the object of the the
the code for this bot will be incredibot
in karate bot so just be an incredible
object
and then
the other player that we will add
is i wish that would get out of my face
is going to be a computer player
race and you can pick different race if
you want i'm going to go with zerg for
now
and the difficulty
will be
hard
um
oh and then we'll add
a whoops let me see here okay boom
okay real time we will set that to be
false for now if that is set to true the
agent has a limited number of time to
like make its calculations and take its
step i don't know what that length of
time is uh feel free to comment down
below i just i honestly just haven't
pulled through the documents to figure
that out but eventually you know if you
were competing against other players it
would be a little unfair if one of those
players is taking like i don't know
an hour per step you know so so this is
just to make sure people are writing
efficient code i suppose
uh so for now we'll set it to false
because who knows we might not write
efficient code here so let's go ahead
and i'll save that and let's go ahead
and run that
yes
uh let me make this a little
let's see oh there we go a little bigger
again i haven't used windows truly in
like years so please
um give me a pass for
being a little clunky here so to run it
it's just python 3 and then the script
name so sc2-1
dot pi
and pray for no errors
the moment of truth
so here okay so here we've got our game
this will be kind of our debug windows
at least for now all it's going to do is
print out the iteration that we're on
but this will be the actual gui of the
game
so here we can see yeah we're printing
out the iterations we have these little
dudes here uh doing some work for us
these are just like our worker units and
uh i guess in the back end they just
automatically are going to be going to
collect these minerals here and i think
i can just i don't know if i can
actually like so you can use your arrow
keys to like move around um we've
already been defeated
you can use your arrow keys to like move
around i find the moving around thing is
kind of clunky also i wish i could like
click on the map to just like move where
i am viewing on the map i don't know if
it's like for competitive reasons you
can't do something like that
but let me know if there's like a quick
way to move via that map but i don't
think there is
uh anyways we'll just load back up again
so i can explain a couple of things uh
before we close out the tutorial um
so these i think if i just i did the
same thing i just did
i think if i like grab the like the top
of the yeah kind of pauses i don't know
if i can actually pause no i can't seem
to pause with escape ah it's so painful
okay whatever anyways these are like
minerals that we have to get and then
you'll see here we can see how many
minerals we have we can also print that
out that's accessible and then we have
gas here that's like that vesping gas
that's like this thing here and this
thing here
later we'll need to collect that as well
and these are just little worker units
in theory these little worker units can
like go and attack but it's kind of
pointless they're very weak so it'd be
unlikely you would be you'd be winning
anything that way but you could
theoretically do that and i think that
is actually the sample code um that they
show
uh on the actual main github here so
yeah here basically all they do is like
we're we're basically up to here and
then all we're doing right now is just
printing the iteration um but then
basically this this basic code is just
saying hey if it's iteration zero take
all your workers and send them to the
enemy
so so that you can do something like
that if you want but um it's not gonna
go well
so um that's it for the introduction and
the next incoming videos what we're
going to be doing is actually like
building buildings kind of working
through the logic of
like how do you build these buildings in
the right order uh how do we defend
ourselves and then finally how do we
attack and hopefully defeat the enemy
and ideally defeat
um an enemy of all three
races so different races have different
strengths and weaknesses um and again
there's there's so much strategy
involved here and again this is why like
i'm just going to stress i don't know
hardly anything about starcraft 2 really
so like i've just written some very
basic ais
but there there's so much here and there
really is a one of the things that makes
this game cool is there is so much depth
here that really it's almost like
infinite competition for you uh if if
you like doing this sort of thing you
can go
very far
or very deep
so anyways that's all for now uh
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
i will see you guys in another video
you